It's been awhile since we last met Alice. It was working on vertex cover.
And actually, the last time we left off, Alice wasn't happy like that.
Actually, Alice was quite unhappy because we proved vertex cover to be NP complete.
The last time we left off, there was little hope for her to ever solve
her vertex cover problem that she was working on.
Now, I promised to show you an intelligent algorithm for vertex cover.
At least one that's more intelligent than brute force.
But in order to do that, let's first start out with a brute force algorithm.
Let's say Alice is running her algorithm on a very simple graph like this.
Just four vertices and five edges.
What her simple algorithm or brute force algorithm was doing was it was considering
all possible assignments of 0 and 1 to the vertices.
For four vertices, we had a total of 16 possibilities that her algorithm needed to look at.
Her algorithm starts out, for example, by saying,
"Oh, let's put no vertices into the vertex cover."
And of course this leaves all edges uncovered so it's not even a valid solution.
Then, it would maybe start out by saying, "Oh, let's put one vertex into the vertex cover."
There's actually four different ways of doing this and at least this time we have some edges covered.
None of these solutions is the valid solution because we still have uncovered edges
and I've drawn a red here so you can better see them.
No valid solution for any of those.
The algorithm continues and says, "Oh then, let's put two vertices into the vertex cover."
Finally, the algorithm has found a valid vertex cover for our small network
but of course it has also found many, many vertex covers that are actually invalid
because not all edges are covered so again redundant, redundant, redundant.
And all the algorithm proceeds and although it has already found a solution where
two vertices are enough for the vertex cover, it now puts three vertices into the vertex cover
which has the advantage that it will always find a valid vertex cover but the disadvantage that
it's totally redundant and unnecessary work.
Same thing if you put all four into the vertex cover. Valid solutions but not the best possible ones.
This is what your brute force algorithm is doing and you can see why brute force is so stupid
because first of all it considers many solutions where you could have immediately said,
"Look, this is not valid." You've taken an edge and none of the two end points is in the vertex cover.
Why even consider all the other possibilities?
As soon as you have an edge that is not covered, you can basically scrap that solution
and go looking for another one and the other thing that her algorithm did that wasn't very smart was
once it had found a solution with two vertices it still tried all the solutions
with three vertices and four vertices.
It could've stopped right here because it knew that it would not be able to find
any vertex cover that is smaller.
And that is the difference between brute force and intelligent force.
In brute force, we go through all of the possible assignments of the vertices into the vertex cover
out of the vertex cover whereas what we're now going to do is we're going to avoid stupid choices.
And that is the basis for intelligent force.